[Music]
the reason for fat G celebrity amongst
the US populists is simple he killed 14
feminist in broad daylight hard pass
from [__] fat G I don't want women
like that what the fart is your [__]
problem I'm going to go eat some cows
now yo you want to go get some steak dog
that's racist as [__] that's racist as
[__] racist that's racist as [__] he's
not a misogynist lady okay [__] you too
okay fat G was untouchable being
canceled wasn't in the cards this time
as the most based homeless man in
Florida to put it simply he took the
Internet by storm 0 to 15,000 Twitter
followers in 2 weeks 30 million views
Andrew and Tristan following him 36
feminists annihilated to date he was the
hero we all needed however weighing in
at a whopping 400 lb still homeless we
decided to help him out in today's video
we're surprising this legendary being
amongst us with over $10,000 supercars
cigars a $50,000 our night out and more
I won't spoil now step one get fat G to
meet us out for a photo
shoot what up my boy how you doing
what's up man what's going on tree
photography look at that oh those are
dope best tree photographer in the game
this is my boy Amir I want you guys to
me what up brother what's up man nice to
meet you man you too bro I saw you I saw
you in Sony's videos man thank you man F
talking about reparations bro you're
just funny as [__] I forgot which one
but I saw you some clips we're going to
have a fun day by the way we're going to
go to a restaurant
later let's go we're going to go drive
around you'll see you're going to have a
lot of fun these cars have a weight
capacity bro these cars only have a
capacity of whatever you want it to bro
so yeah endless [__] I actually got a
job now man I've been working my ass off
towards finding a job I'm actually under
three 400 lb now I weighed myself it's a
crazy number but 396 so what are you
you're down you're down weight yeah for
sure so I'll put it to you like this man
I spoke to a doctor we did blood test I
found out that I was pretty low on
testosterone hence the boobs so uh got
my my life in order dude got some
testosterone being injected into my ass
every day and are you getting boners in
the morning now not yet dude I'm still
waiting to see my weeb GOP I personally
have a couple really strong views and
like I'm going to say this to the camera
I I I really believe this I believe that
all Muslims are terrorists right I
believe that they're really bad like
what do you think about that this guy's
a [__] poverty ass version of John
zerka dude what do you what do you think
about that I think you're immature bro
and why is that well not you but your
view is immature and what do you
disagree with about that everything
they're not all terrorists dude I mean
what about America America's major
[__] terrorist organization uh it's
worse than that but yeah like what do
you what do you uh what do you think
about my statement how how can we dub
Islamic culture as terrorists when we're
we're far worse I mean look at Obama
dude he [__] bombed the [__] out of
[__] seven Middle Eastern countries
look at [__] George Bush his father
everybody dog I think I have to come
clean about something you're gay that
and [__] and I'm actually
Muslim all right cool so I was [__]
with you my name is Amir Hussein I was
[__] with you the whole time bro the
moment like you said my name is Amir I'm
pretty sure I realized oh he's probably
in the Arabic culture yeah no actually
just the terrorist culture the Muslim
culture wants to gift you $11,000 cash
all right since you passed the test the
Muslim culture wants to give you
$1,000 take it bro really yeah all for
you bro I'm the Muslims yeah bro from
the Muslims Bram Alum asalam alayum my
[__] thank you
bro appreciate shukan Habibi and Habib
yeah bro what's why though huh why you
passed the test bro we had a test I
don't care about a test bro I don't care
about money enjoy it bro bro I just came
to hang out with you guys but you don't
have to give me money bro guess what
coffee's on your ass he definitely had a
good reaction to the 1K but um he has no
idea that we're about to give him 10
racks this is going to be crazy I wonder
what he's going to do hopefully he
[__] puts it to good use we wanted to
get you another little gift this is a
$5,000 box of cigar both of these combin
are like 5K BR this brand go on Google
search up world's most expensive cigar
this is the highest tier brand in the
world they have the world Guinness World
Record one of their cigars sold for over
a million almost like 1.4 million I
think hey guys if you want cigars 1.6
mil shipped to Dubai that's the top [__]
bro if you want smoke that later that's
crazy dude yeah should be able to sell
sell those get some cash too cigar G BR
we got faty with the 1K and the 5K box
of cigars now we're to go take some cool
shots you to do and surprise him with
the 10 B you know what I'm saying yo
look at my new car bro I just got that
that's my new whip hardig it's not a
it's not a
[Music]
I've been tra for a
while it feels like everything is
starting to fall
down so I started running for
miles and when I get home you'll just
fix me with your I just getting lighter
got to ask a favor do you want to tag
along if I run away just say Okay F you
like I haven't really seen as much as
your your photography side that shit's
really impressive I know photography is
your passion and you've like been
reinvesting a lot into this like what
what what are the steps that are going
to need um need to be taken for you to
actually like be able to move in
somewhere like just more work man create
my income and go from there you know
what I mean like I want to work for for
me to get a place you know what I mean
like that's the only way it feels right
well we got you an extra little gift
Amir you want to it's uh it's in the car
I look this way bro so something under
my shirt I got you a little bit of gift
uh we got you $10,000 bro in
cash get the [__] out of here
look yo look Sony Sony told me what you
have going on your passion I saw your
passion as [__] we want to get you in a
place we want to get you going that's
why I told you want to help out with
your business too dude this is Si here
bro take this [__] all you bro 10 B wait
where's the Muslim test the Muslim test
was the onek
reverse 1K plus 10K plus we got some
other [__] plus we're going to help your
business yeah dude we got you bro hope
you like it bro you got to put that in
the car before someone steals that [__]
[Music]
[__] I know you've been grinding you're
down weight you've been working hey keep
it up bro it's a big future bro we all
started somewhere bro I started at that
rock [__] bottom with no money when I
was started my business bro and it feels
good to be able to help and also too
we're creating entertaining great
content obviously you're going to be
able to go ahead and do whatever
hopefully you can get yourself a place
also too I want to make sure that you're
taking care of your health you're eating
the right food so I spoke to Sony I'm
going to be taking care of a gym
membership also too I'm going to be
taking care of a of a of a of a meal
plan so you can eat more healthy like we
saw you [__] eating the sugar earlier
I cared about you I was like bro what
the [__] mother the [__] we're going
to make we're going to make make you
even better right so we got a couple of
things set up but at the end of the day
the number one thing to get what you
want in life is to execute right and we
just want to boost you to where you need
to be so right now I hope this helps bro
we just hope that you stay on the right
track bro you're on the right track
actually momentum bro it's one of the
realest things in the world sometimes
all you need it is man it really is dude
I'm I'm mind boggled BR I really really
really am I don't know what the [__] to
say dude I got to tell you something man
you know that I'm getting late you know
that it's not over tonight right the
surprises are not over we have maybe
something level 100K gift what the [__]
we have more fun coming right we already
did a lot of fun yeah we got some cool
[__] but we did the we did the
materialistic stuff now it's time to
have some fun experience we have a
surprise tonight me and Sony want to
bring you somewhere so we'll just have
to see where the [__] that is I'm I'm
super excited to go myself bro yes it's
time for me to stop jerking off and bang
bang bang bang bang bang bang off to the
next spot what's up boys we're getting
in the Uber right now we're going to be
surprising faty going to the club we're
here with a bunch of other online money
[Music]
guys I got smoke in my my my system one
hell of a timeing I'm cling the blind
watching my back my life on the line
smoking my eye my mind my system of
timeing my my the line ask neighbors why
they all up in my business get the [__]
my face I'm trying to
live I don't have Lim the poli's coming
yeah we only have a minute I've been
running running for my life St I haven't
been it's all in my mind someone's
watching me I hope I'm wrong must be
late I'm too far gone brains destroyed
I'm so annoyed all my memories and
Polaroid nothing feels AV void I can't
swing like Floyd with the to enjoy your
paranoid smoking